as soon as this happened I called Derek
he answers he goes hello and I said hey
how [ __ ] long did it take for you to
make this documentary yeah yeah and he
goes weeks I said weeks you spent weeks
making this documentary I think it's
brilliant yeah and I just want to say
thank you I don't know what good will
come of it but good will come of it is
it in some ways liberating this is way
bigger than me and so for a second I'm
like oh cool the weight has been lifted
I apologize because I lied because I
deceived people because I misled people
again I've known it I deserve it all and
what I would say to anybody who wants to
retaliate or go somewhere else go
somewhere else right what I would ask
you got to be loyal to the facts that
people are hurting and hating at record
rates see you're saying it doesn't need
to be liver King who's pointing these
things out it could be Derek from more
places guess what every one of them
saying the same thing they're all saying
liver is King